what really fundamentally is the  difference between neurons and other  cells of course evolutionarily they're  reusing Machinery that has been around  for a very long time since the time of  bacteria basically right so our multi  our unicellular ancestors had a lot of  the same machinery and and even I mean  of course axons are very can be very  long but but uh there are sort of  intermediate structures right there are  tunneling nanotubes and things that  allow cells to connect to maybe five or  ten diameter cell diameters away right  so so not terribly long but but also not  immediate neighbors necessarily so that  kind of architecture has been around for  a while and people like growl so well  look at  um  but a very brain-like electrical  signaling in bacterial Colony so this is  you know I think I think Evolution began  to reuse this toolkit specifically of  using this kind of communication to  scale up